these are terrifying times for the
people of Samoa told to stay indoors and
the vulnerable ordered to mark out their
homes in a medieval like practice the
red flag is a sign that somebody inside
is awaiting an urgent visit from doctors
who are going from community to
community to administer vaccines only
officials or people trying to get to
hospital or s'posed to be on the streets
post any problems for fast movements or
party for LCL Alessio the warnings came
too late
her child is one of the dozens of
youngsters who've died from measles on
Samoa very big lost
Samoas government has declared a state
of emergency but stands accused of
acting too late children are dying and
in front of us in front of them and in
front of other families in the intensive
care unit Samoa is not alone in its
failure to prevent the spread of measles
the World Health Organization is
reporting a three-fold global increase
in cases this is a really important
lesson to show how important vaccines
are to keep a population and to keep
people safe from preventable diseases
children under the age of five have
proved particularly vulnerable but
experts say their suffering is avoidable
with improved immunization programs and
a willingness to implement them Lisa
Holland Sky News